been an explosion of companies over the
last five to ten years that have been
backed through venture capital many of
them on the day they took that venture
capital believed they were gonna build
the next great you know billion dollar
plus start-up venture capitalists
believe that and everyone kind of gave
it their best effort right but where we
find them today is it didn't play out
the way that everyone thought it was and
so that may be because of things under
their control or not under their control
there's kind of a whole gamut there but
my question to you is given the model
that you've employed do you think that
there is a opportunity to go get the
previously venture capital funded
businesses that didn't scale to those
billion dollar companies and start to
actually kind of wean them off the
dependency on venture capital and push
them into something that looks more like
a call kind of a tiny business meaning
the businesses that you guys normally
look at like can you transition or is it
once they've taken the venture capital
no matter how badly it goes it's kind of
a fatal shot and they can't transition
back to a sustainable business model I
think it's like drug addiction right so
it's like heroin you shoot heroin a
couple times there's people who get out
and then there's people who just they
unfortunately don't do well with it and
so I think that I'm really really
excited whenever we got the opportunity
to take a venture backed business and
dust it off and clean up the PNL and get
it back to its former glory that's
really exciting we just did that with a
business called meteor that we bought
that andreessen horowitz had put 50
million dollars into and it was a
wonderful business and had great
customers and was growing at 30 plus
percent a year but it just wasn't
growing at a hundred or 200 percent a
year and so the business had to pivot
and when they pivoted there is this
whorfin business leftover and it was
really cool we were able to buy it and
reengage the community and plug in a
great team and start actively working on
it again so that's been really cool and
I think there's gonna be a lot of
opportunities like that over the next
year or two I think that venture it's
not that venture is gonna go away it's
that venture is only going to fund the
very best deals so you see
with companies like notion that are
incredibly hot they're growing really
fast or in a great space they've got all
the right metrics those guys will be
able to raise fine but the business
that's growing at 20% a year 30% a year
40% a year even may not be able to raise
or if it's just a slightly more
challenging environment and I think
those are the opportunities that we're
very excited about where we can help
them we knopf the venture juice and
build a sustainable business and there's
obviously pain associated with that
right a lot of these companies have been
run in ways that their P&L is just
totally out of whack and you know they
they've done some crazy stuff and we see
pnls of these businesses every day and
it just boggles the mind we we basically
we've been around for 15 years for the
first ten years we couldn't even get a
bank loan we could barely get credit
cards right we just had no access to
capital at all and it made us incredibly
incredibly disciplined you know
operators we had to be otherwise we'd go
to business that was all we had and so
when I see these businesses it just
blows my mind like I can't believe how
much money they burn and it's staggering
can you take a business that's done that
right and to be clear I think you're
saying this as well as I am that's the
model they're in right so it's not like
they're doing anything that's malicious
or bad it's just they've been given a
lot of money and use the money to grow
right but if you have a team that has
through muscle memory been trained to
spend a lot of money and try to hit that
high growth is it possible to then take
that business with the same team and
kind of retrain them to go after the
more sustainable model or like in the
business that you bought do you have to
basically bring in a new team and then
you can just take the actual assets with
a new team and can do it I mean we
talked to founders all the time who say
I wish I never is venture this isn't
right for me I don't want to shoot for
the moon I'm risk-averse can you buy out
my venture investors and we look at
those deals all the time in that
instance yes because they've self opted
into that and they think so if I had a
venture investor private equity investor
come to me and say hey look I own 60% of
this
you know they've burned through all this
money and they're not in that camp
that's a totally different story we
would really have to think hard about
that because not only are you doing
management change but you're changing
the business model and the P&L and stuff
well we would look for in a venture back
business is something that is ultimately
sustainable with high margins that's
simple and it's still doing well despite
having this crazy venture stuff going on
what kills me is seeing these businesses
where the unit economics don't make
sense where they spend five dollars to
make one dollar of revenue and then they
burn three dollars in operating costs or
whatever those are the businesses we
would not be interested in the ones that
I love are the ones where if you just
dust off the P&L a little bit and you
operate it a little more conservatively
there's a wonderful profitable business
underneath yeah the speaking of kind of
these d2c companies or the high CAC type
businesses I think it goes back to our
conversation with the Joe Rogan's the
kylie jenner's like I think we're seeing
the rise of entrepreneurs who are able
to drastically reduce that cost of
acquisition because they have the
built-in audience right where you're
almost seeing the business models that
didn't work five years ago will come
back it'll just be with a different unit
economic basis and it's because the
person now started a company will
actually have the customers there rather
than have to go acquire them yeah if you
own an amazing busy office building and
you have tens of thousands of people in
a lobby and you can start your own
coffee shop and put it in there you're
gonna sell a lot of coffee no matter
what you do it could be the worst coffee
in the world
I think that's what you see with Kylie
Jenner is she starts a makeup brand it
barely matters it's just branded and hot
and she can promote it on her own
channel for free
I think there's gonna be a lot more of
that happening and I again like going
back to she's done this you know she's
become a billionaire I don't know what
the exact numbers would look like or
whatever but I think if you think about
it if she could do a digital product
right where she can actually have true
95 or 99 percent margins that's where
things can get really crazy and like the
Rogan kind of numbers especially if it's
recurring revenue because at the end of
the day
then you have the best sass business in
the world you have no rnd cost yeah and
I guess as part of that do you think
that's where this goes like do you see a
world where these influencers start to
get away from building merch and kind of
the easy kind of low hanging fruit stuff
and they actually started to say I want
to build software products whether
they're mobile apps or web-based stuff
and that's like that becomes the Holy
Grail
well you look at sam harris you know he
has this huge podcast he's doing this
subscription thing and then we helped
him build his meditation app right and
it's the exact same thing he's publicly
speaking about meditation he's written
books about it and he has a loyal
audience well it's perfectly logical to
say hey you should use my meditation app
you know me you trust me and I have this
free acquisition channel you know and
now he's got this whole other business
right there that you know it wasn't that
complicated for us to help him we used
metal a band metal have built built the
meditation app and designed it and you
know I think it was profitable
relatively quickly